[Applause]
[Music]
in the last few decades israel has
become one of the most important
technological powers
in the world amazingly with a little
more than 8 million inhabitants this
country has more than
4 000 tech companies cisco paypal google
facebook apple and intel
are only some of the many companies that
develop new products in israel
but how did such a small and turbulent
country become one of the world's
innovation leaders
well we're going to answer that question
in today's video
israel is one of the most controversial
countries in the world and
in truth it's pretty difficult to talk
about it without having to refer to wars
religion
and various political conflicts however
in this video we're going to try and
we're going to try and shed some light
on a very different side of this country
because dear viewer in the last few
decades
israel has become one of the world's
greatest technological powers and this
is something pretty surprising as we
mentioned israel has over 4 000
tech-based companies and
80 of the largest 500 companies in the
world have subsidiaries here oriented
towards research and innovation
in fact tel aviv right after silicon
valley is the most important
technological center
in the world and although it may seem
impossible given its size
israel is the country in the world with
the third most companies listed on the
nasdaq
this is only behind the united states
and china
israel has more companies listed on this
market than spain italy france germany
and the netherlands
all put together so how about some
specific examples
well here they are at the time of this
video going out most of the next
iphone's hardware is being developed in
israel further many of google's
innovations are made in israel and
intel the world's leader in microchips
owes most of its success to the
innovations of its israeli subsidiary
which by the way has 11
000 workers and is one of the largest
companies in the entire country
and well even microsoft has been
considered a semi-israeli company
it is a hub of innovation with top-notch
computer science academic
institutes and revolutionary
technologies
paypal ibm cisco amazon facebook these
are the companies that we use
every day whose technology relies a lot
on r d that is done in israel this
sector makes up more
than 12 percent of its national gdp and
half of its exports
alright so now you might be wondering
how did they achieve
such success now cultural factors are
usually considered here but today we
want to focus
on three political keys that were
essential in this process
[Music]
the 1980s in israel are remembered as a
terrible decade especially from the
economic perspective back then the
country was going through a tough crisis
inflation between 1980 and 1985 exceeded
every year deficit and public debt were
an almost unbearable financial burden on
the economy and in general people felt
handcuffed due to excessive state
intervention to a large extent israel
was very dependent on the help coming
from different parts of the world
and even though the situation started to
stabilize by the end of the 80s
right at that time there was a massive
arrival of jewish people from different
parts of the soviet union in very little
time 800 000 new people
arrived in the country and now don't
forget to put some perspective on this
number in relative terms that would be
like 70 million
immigrants arriving to the united states
and now the question for israel was
fairly clear how could they generate
jobs for so many people in such a
depressed economy
israel's only option was to reinvent
itself
[Music]
at first the government tried to
encourage the newcomers to create
companies with subsidies that would
promote the work of entrepreneurs but
they soon realized that this method
didn't result in very prosperous
companies
immigrants had no experience in
management and they lacked commercial
knowledge
and they really got any financing i mean
after all who would want to invest their
money in a turbulent country like israel
and this is when the government realized
that the key was to bet on attracting
international venture capital that is
money used for new ideas
and new companies in order to do so they
came up with the yosma program thanks to
yozma the government created
10 funds of venture capital and
allocated 100 million dollars to be used
under these conditions
each fund capable of levying 12 million
private investors
would receive 8 million in public
investment in exchange the government
would keep 40
of the property but in case the
investment was successful the inventors
could get these shares from the
government just by giving the
government's money back with a small
interest rate
so in 10 years all the funds that came
to israel at that time
raised about 15 million billion dollar
which were invested into local companies
so if things worked well the profits
would be mainly for the investors and if
things didn't work so well the
government would share in the losses now
this might seem unfair but the truth is
that the public investment was
relatively small and also the government
expected to get the losses back from the
new taxes generated by these new
companies and all of the jobs that they
would create
the idea was to fire things up and then
continue to reap the ongoing benefits
since then most public programs in
israel have followed this same system
and the truth is the results they
couldn't have been any better
international money started to arrive
there was funding for
almost any idea and in the first eight
years alone the number of funds rose
from 20 to
513 as a result israel today has one of
the best ecosystems for entrepreneurial
capital in the world and according to
the last oecd data the investment
available for new companies
exceeds 150 dollars per person
per year to make a comparison of that
figure in spain it's only about 3.5
which is a solid 40 times less the key
in this process is that venture capital
doesn't just bring money with this money
also comes expertise and
contacts
[Music]
immigration it could be said that israel
is the country which has bet on
immigration the most
one out of every three citizens has been
born abroad and nine out of ten are
either immigrants or the children or the
grandchildren of immigrants
this is an impressive migratory number
that explains the growth of its
population from eight hundred thousand
inhabitants in 1948 to more than eight
million today in this latest round of
immigration
nearly 50 french jews arrived at tel
aviv's ben-gurion airport
so in little more than 60 years the
population has multiplied by 10. israel
is in fact a political
and historical exception because their
founding documents so to speak its
constitution
expresses the need to have an open
immigration policy let's examine the law
of return which is still in force today
and was created in 1950.
every jew has the right to come to this
country as an olleh
law of return article 1. and don't get
this wrong this is not a minor issue
immigration has contributed to the
economic miracle
as much as any other factor no matter
what populist politicians say whose aim
is often just to get votes
the wealthiest nations are usually the
ones with more immigrants
among other reasons it's usually because
immigrants have higher rates of
entrepreneurship
and also because immigrants help boost
international trade
especially with their countries of
origin by the way if you are interested
about immigration i'm going to link over
to some videos about that
that we've put together at the end of
this video
[Music]
education
the quality of israeli education is
almost a national hallmark in 1918
30 years before the founding of the
state of israel jewish settlers founded
the hebrew university of jerusalem
israel today has one of the highest
rates of people with college degrees and
the country has a lot of success with
fusion companies
universities finance for israeli
universities relies mainly on projects
financed by private companies so there
are reasons for universities to
collaborate with them further they have
achieved the best rate of business
creation in the oecd
knowledge transfer is essential this is
taking the university and professional
world closer together
well so so far we've seen the main keys
to success but there are other
influential factors
for example there is the jewish hutzpah
a tendency to question everything
something that is key in jewish culture
the military service is also a
surprising and important thing as it
helps social mobilization forcing young
people from different social classes to
interact and hey while compulsory
military service
isn't exactly great it does have some
positive effects in this case now we
could also discuss for example
netanyahu's reforms of 2003 which were
essential to israel's success but
i think it's better to leave that for a
future video the thing is thanks to all
of what we've discussed today
since the 1980s israel has doubled its
population multiplied the number of jobs
by four
and grown by an annual average rate of 4
percent today its gdp per capita
is higher than other countries like
spain or italy so what do you think will
israel consolidate itself as the leading
technological power in the world
could its model be repeated for other
countries let us know what you think in
the comments below and hey if you did
like this video be sure to hit that like
button below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every
monday and every thursday
and as always thank you for watching and
i'll see you in the next video
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there